since the Avengers in 2012 Mark
Ruffalo's Incredible Hulk has become a
fan favorite but as of yet there are no
plans for him to have a solo film we do
know he likes to smash puny gods and
luckily it looks like he'll be up to
more of his old tricks in sci-fi fantasy
buddy cop movie thor ragnarok I'm Simon
and this is your gamma radiation news
updates although Hulk was one of the
first heroes of the Marvel Universe to
get his own movie a rights issue between
Disney and Universal has meant a second
solo film it yet to appear however the
green-skinned Avenger will return in the
upcoming thor ragnarok and it sounds
like he'll be getting plenty of screen
time Mark Ruffalo who plays Hulk and his
alter-ego Bruce Banner was interviewed
by ETonline about his new film now you
see me too and was asked about thor
ragnarok while obviously cagey about
specifics Ruffalo did suggest that you
would have a key role in the film I
think it will be smashing you'll see a
lot more hope the Hulk gets hopia the
Hulk Hulk's out Hulk e'er and bigger
Ruffalo also commented on Cate
Blanchett's villainous role which was
confirmed last week she plays the worst
of the worst so evil she is going to
kill us it's such a great part she gets
to play launch it and Ruffalo will join
Jeff Goldblum and Karl Urban in the
movie alongside Chris Hemsworth and Tom
Hiddleston who plays low key the film is
to be directed by Tyco with TT in
February were TT revealed to hit fix
that one of the discussions that was
taking place behind the scenes was
exactly how much Hulk should speak in
the movie at the moment there's a big
conversation that's happening about how
far to push that whether or not the hope
should be verbal I think a lot of these
conversations have more to do with
what's going to come up in future movies
so I think a lot of those decisions are
large group decisions rather than
anything to do with just me or the
writer they have a lot of stuff that
they have to consider but they do think
that's the best way to track it I think
we all want that I think we all want to
see that development call Ragnarok hit
cinemas on November third 2017 what do
you think about Thor and hold
an intergalactic road trip let me know
in the comments or come find me on
twitter i'm at the j connaught thanks
for watching and for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot